ce soir enquête on vous parle des
dissidents saoudien qui vivent dans la
peur même ici au canada
j'ai reçu beaucoup de messages de
menaces d'insultés plus de 100 messages
par jour j'ai reçu un appel de quelqu'un
qui me disait on va te tuer il refuse de
se taire
malgré les menaces et même après le
meurtre horrible du journaliste jamal
khashoggi qui a scandalisé le monde
entier le gouvernement veut faire taire
tout le monde à l'intérieur comme à
l'extérieur du pays
quelqu'un doit dire non ça doit cesser
un drame qui survient alors que les
relations entre le canada et l'arabie
saoudite n'était pas très bonne tu as
été absolument inacceptable on exige
encore des meilleures réponses de
l'arabie saoudite et ce soit on vous
fait découvrir à quel point plusieurs
d'entre eux sont en danger
il sait ils m'ont dit ta vie ne nous
coûtera qu'une balle dans la tête
bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
à
toute forme de dissidence toute forme de
critique envers le régime était tout
fait l'arabie saoudite se fait critiquer
depuis des années à travers le monde
pour son traitement des militants des
droits de la personne emprisonnée et
torturée
aujourd'hui son emprise déborde du
royaume le gouvernement veut faire taire
tout le monde à l'intérieur comme à
l'extérieur du pays
il utilise la peur pour imposer le
silence
je reçois des menaces chaque jour même
des menaces de mort sur twitter youtube
snapshot même exilé les saoudiens
critiques du régime demeurent des cibles
et ils sont de plus en plus nombreux au
canada après l'assassinât de jamal
rachid j je me suis dit ça suffit le
silence je suis prêt à parler pour
raconter aux gens ce qui se passe
vraiment en arabie saoudite
c'est comme le royaume du silence là bas
[Applaudissements]
installé dans la région de toronto se
fait des années que raja al idrissi
reçoit des insultes et des menaces de
toutes sortes
ce sont des gens comme toi qui incite
les jeunes hommes et femmes à désobéir
le roi
la peine pour traîtrise du pays est
grande raja à la dhr ici n'est qu'une
chienne et rang au canada
j'ai reçu un appel de quelqu'un qui me
disait elle va te suit ta vie ne nous
coûtera qu'une balle dans la tête haute
arrivé comme réfugié au canada il ya
près de 20 ans elle se décrit comme une
dissidente saoudienne qui n'hésite pas à
s'opposer aux décisions du gouvernement
du pays qu'elle a fui je me suis
toujours exprimé mais en maintenant loin
des projecteurs spot
la plupart des menaces arrive par les
réseaux sociaux tu te crois que j au
canada mais un jour tu viendras au moyen
orient et on attraperait we work hard
tatouages et c'est ce qui arriva en 2017
mohammed bin salman mb s est alors le
nouveau prince héritier d'arabie
saoudite
il gagne de plus en plus d'emprise sur
la gouverne du pays
il se présente comme un réformateur
malgré tout les dissidents comme raja
continuent d'être des cibles alors
qu'elle se rend en egypte pour rejoindre
son père mourant les menaces virtuelles
prennent une nouvelle forme bien réel
deux hommes marché à mes côtés ils m'ont
dit que si je parlais du gouvernement
saoudien
il serait quoi faire avec moi raja dit
en reconnaître ils seraient des services
de renseignements saoudiens
non ils m'ont dit maintenant que tu
arrivé en egypte d'où on peut faire ce
qu'on veut avant que tu retournes au
canada garde le silence et ne dit rien
contre le gouvernement plusieurs mois
s'écoulent après cet incident puis au
mois d'août 2018
une querelle diplomatique éclate entre
le canada et l'arabie saoudite
dans un message twitter le canada
exhorte des autorités saoudiennes à
libérer de prison des militants des
droits des femmes en afrique la crise
d'oka maroc et l'arabie saoudite
n'accepte pas de se faire faire la leçon
par le canada
ryad exige le départ de l'ambassadeur
canadien et annonce le retrait de ses
étudiants au canada sur twitter
raja encourage les étudiants à rester
ici j'ai essayé de leur expliquer les
possibilité d'émigrer ici
sa sortie ne passe pas inaperçu en
arabie saoudite
elle dit avoir rapidement reçu un appel
de sa famille un de mes frères a été
arrêté et détenu pendant presque un jour
et il pense que c'est de ma faute
le démembrement appuyé sur le pour la
disparition et la torture appuyez sur le
2 siraj appelé faire le style dissidente
plutôt discrète ce n'est pas le cas de
ghanem al massa rire qui utilise un
humour cinglant et provocateur pour
faire passer son message
daoudi ceux de ses membres de la famille
royale avant crois qu'ils sont au dessus
de toute critique
personne n'oserait rire de mes chronos
chelem il a quitté l'arabie saoudite en
2003 et vit maintenant à l'ombre ces
vidéos ridiculisant la famille royale
lui amène son lot de menaces un ami du
canada ma visite et on est allé prendre
un café
cet ami c'est aaron bender un homme
d'affaires torontois spécialisé dans les
négociations avec des entreprises en
amérique du nord notamment qui oeuvrent
au moyen orient
en août dernier il était à londres avec
ghanam
quand deux saoudiens s'en sont pris à
lui on marchait depuis quelques minutes
et c'est là qu'ils se sont mis à crier
après lui charest
ils m'ont attaqué verbalement puis
physiquement ces dix ans pour qui te
prends-tu pour parler de la famille
royale saoudienne
ils ont essayé de l'attaquer plusieurs
fois je me suis interposé mais il y en a
qui a réussi à frapper ghanem
ghanem est convaincu que cette attaque
était orchestrée par les autorités
saoudiennes
c'est un message à tous les dissidents
on peut vous atteindre n'importe où même
en angleterre
ok la police ouvre une enquête sur
l'incident
aucune arrestation n'a encore eu lieu le
gouvernement a envoyé deux représentants
accompagné de mes frères ils les ont
dépêché à montréal pour me rencontrer
plus près de nous au québec
un autre dissident omar abdul aziz n'est
pas à l'abri des tentacules du régime
saoudien qui le suit sur les réseaux
sociaux
il s'est confié à nos collègues de siby
si il essayait de me convaincre de
retourner là bas ils disaient on veut
changer le système pour faire des choses
pour les jeunes je leur ai dit non merci
potes
il raconte qu'après son refus deux de
ses frères et ses amis là bas sont
arrêtés n'aurais jamais pensé qu'il
viserait des proches ou des amis des
gens qui n'ont rien à voir avec la
politique
l'étau autour d' omar continue de se
resserrer
il apprend que son téléphone est infecté
par un logiciel qui permet d'espionner
ses communications avec n'importe qui
même à partir de l'arabie saoudite
je suis convaincu que le gouvernement
saoudien et derrière ça ce qui
m'attriste c'est que je ne sais pas
combien de personnes ont été mises en
danger une bombe
une de ces personnes jamal khashoggi
avec ont marre ils échangeaient sur
divers projets dont celui de fournir des
cartes téléphoniques à des
collaborateurs qui pourraient ensuite
s'en servir sur les réseaux sociaux sans
être retracés par les autorités
saoudiennes
leur but contre attaquer face à ce que
certains appellent les mouches ses
comptes pro régime qui chaque jour
inondent les dissidents d' insulte sur
twitter par exemple en décembre dernier
il avait partagé avec cnn certains de
ces messages avec jamal khashoggi comme
celui ci dans lequel le journaliste
décrit le prince héritier comme une bête
à la recherche de victimes des messages
qui auraient pu être captée en arabie
saoudite
le piratage de mon téléphone a joué un
rôle important dans ce qui est arrivé à
jamal j'en suis désolé ghanem al massa
rire a lui aussi été visé par une
tentative d'infection par logiciel
espion dans un texto la même chose est
arrivée à un autre dissident bien connu
à londres je ne voyais pas de risque car
ça venait du ministère de la justice
alors gelé ou vers yahia à siri a quitté
l'arabie saoudite en 2013
il a depuis fondé une organisation de
défense des droits de la personne
il multiplie les contacts pour
sensibiliser d'autres gouvernements pour
problèmes qu'ils dénoncent en arabie
saoudite
quand je publie ses photos
plusieurs personnes disent de moi que je
suis un traître qu'il faut être sans
pitié pour les très très fort d'acteurs
qu'il faut les tuer
assassinat espionnage de téléphone
emprisonnement des proches
insultes et menaces de mort tout de même
pour eux la lutte doit se poursuivre une
association doit dire non ça doit cesser
les réformes doivent commencer par la
libération des prisonniers d'opinion et
par la liberté d'expression michel forst
et rapporteur spécial de l'onu
il est régulièrement en contact avec des
défenseurs des droits de la personne
même si plusieurs dissidents demeure
déterminée il remarque que pour d'autres
militants la peur s'est installée depuis
le meurtre de jamal khashoggi j'ai
rencontré plusieurs militants qui après
cette affaire monde y avoir plus peur
que par le passé se retournant dans la
rue pour regarder s'ils sont suivis
n'hésitant pas à voyager sous des
identités parfois un peu différente pour
éviter d'être suivi par des agents du
pays c'est plus compliqué maintenant
d'obtenir de l'information de
l'intérieur les gens ont peur de se
faire espionner par le gouvernement avec
toutes ces arrestations et la répression
contre les militants des droits de la
personne
notre mission est vraiment plus
difficile après la pause des saoudiens
qui sont forcés de s'espionner entre eux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
2017 l'arabie saoudite et son prince
héritier projette une nouvelle image
plus moderne et ouverte sur le monde
wahaha
les prix du pétrole sont à la baisse or
le royaume veut transformer son économie
les femmes auront droit de conduire et
des cinémas ouvriront on sent que
l'arabie saoudite envie de montrer
qu'elle progresse que le que le nouveau
leader du pays est un leader
progressiste l'arabie saoudite voulait
être pays modérés normal tennis
rauraques a été ambassadeur du canada en
l'arabie saoudite de 2015 à 2018
persona non grata à la bat depuis le
fameux tweet canadien du mois d'août
dernier le programme de réformes vision
2030 du prince héritier
couvrez plusieurs champs d'activités
réforme du système d'éducation
diversification de l'économie
des ouvertures dans le secteur du
divertissement espèces
mais tout ça n'avait rien à voir avec
une ouverture politique pour être plus
direct que ça voulait dire taisez vous
et à l'eau si c'est bien ce qui aurait
fait cet homme qui n'avait rien d'un
dissident
il menait une vie tranquille en arabie
saoudite mais même pour quelqu'un comme
lui
une simple erreur peut coûter cher afin
de protéger ses amis et ses proches
toujours là bas nous l'appellerons said
nous avons aussi modifié quelques
détails de son récit afin d'éviter
qu'ils ne soient reconnus les services
de renseignements - approchés ils m'ont
dit on sait ce que tu as dit et où tu
l'as dit saïd est un saoudien de la
minorité chiite
je suis une personne parmi des milliers
qui parlait mon erreur ça a été de
parler au mauvais endroit
selon lui ses ennuis ont commencé quand
il a critiqué le régime
en discutant avec des collègues sur son
lieu de travail l'un d'eux a rapporté
les propos de saïd aux autorités
je pensais qu'après tout notre temps
passé comme collègue ils auraient pu se
taire ou au moins me pardonner mais ce
n'est pas ce qu'il a fait saïd
dénonçaient la répression du
gouvernement contre la communauté chiite
mais aussi l'intervention de l'armée
dans le pays voisin
ce qui se passe au yémen est un désastre
l'arabie saoudite est critiqué de toutes
parts pour son rôle dans la guerre ou y
est même une des pires crises
humanitaires actuels dans le monde
j'ai perdu mon emploi et je savais que
c'était parce que j'avais parlé peu de
temps après un agent des renseignements
le contact il veut lui passer un message
il m'a dit tu sais ce qu'on fait avec
les traîtres partout dans le monde
je savais qu'il voulait dire que je
risquais de me faire tuer ensuite il a
dit tu dois collaborer avec nous pour
qu'on puisse te pardonner il voulait que
gestion des gens depuis que mohamed bin
salman est arrivé au pouvoir et qu'il a
promis des réformes
une modernisation de l'état en fait
qu'on voit nouchet ministe
internationale c'est plutôt une
recrudescence de l'étouffement de la
dissidence
même des leaders religieux critiques du
régime peuvent être arrêtés mais l'an
dernier c'est l'emprisonnement de
plusieurs militantes des droits de la
personne qui fait surtout la manchette
du nombre logen à la clown diplômé de
l'université de la colombie-britannique
et samar badaoui celle dont parlait le
canada dans son fameux tweet à l'arabie
saoudite
on n'a pas de nouvelles précises sur
leur état évidemment on est très inquiet
parce qu'on sait qu'il ya eu des
allégations de mauvais traitements dans
la prison saoudienne saoud ben brahim de
se pendre la chaussée curie tennis
rauraques connaissait plusieurs des
femmes arrêtées
il a du mal à comprendre ce qu'on leur
reproche en matière de sécurité
nationale
c'est difficile à croire d'après ce que
je connais de ses femmes ses objectifs
visaient plutôt des changements en
arabie saoudite comme ceux déjà amorcée
en matière de droits des femmes autour
des changements aussi aux lois sur la
tutelle qui confère aux hommes une
reprise dans divers domaines sur les
femmes en arabie saoudite depuis 2014
une loi très très vaste une loi
antiterroriste a été mis en place dont
on considère comme terroriste à peu près
qui compte toute forme de dissidence et
quiconque ose s'opposer à l'état une des
premières victimes de cette loi et
l'avocat walid abu al khayr l'ex époux
de samar badaoui c'est aussi lui qui a
représenté l'un des plus célèbres
prisonniers d'opinion le frère de samar
badaoui incarcéré depuis 2012
si l'appel
un fois deux fois par semaine ça dépend
son moral amstaff haidar la femme de
riffs vite à sherbrooke avec leurs trois
enfants depuis 2013
voyez les frais pour les droits des
lampes pour les droits des femmes pour
héliporter conscience pour ses écrits
raïs a été condamné à 1000 coups de
fouet dix ans de prison
en plus de dix ans sans sortir de
l'arabie saoudite comme bien d'autres et
sauf avait vu plusieurs signes
encourageants récemment de weeds ou
milla de 7 arnaud beaucoup des
changements et notre avis d'état c'est
comme les femmes maintenant elle a le
droit pour moi reconduit où on a hélas
le cinéma ne rater sous dit les lille
police religieuse maintenant et
l'appellent les le pouvoir comme avant
mais hélas quelques as thouars ça arrive
c'est calme
ah les problèmes avec canada comme les
montres dans les jeunes alésiens mettre
à chercher ça on sait pas un cas ce que
ça arrive
après ça malgré ces inquiétudes elle
garde espoir de voir son mari libérée
elle est encouragée notamment par une
récente rencontre avec le premier
ministre trudeau à sherbrooke
il m'a donné les promesses pour les plus
ratées demain il va fait quelque chose
c'est le cas le plus fameux le fait
d'arrêter une personne a pu emblématique
c'est aussi un moyen de dire aux autres
nous attaquons à celui ci donc si vous
continuez vos activités
eh bien vous en payer le prix les cas
célèbres font la manchette d'autres
saoudien pris dans les griffes du régime
cependant vivre leur drame dans
l'anonymat le plus complet
ils ne m'ont pas tuer parce qu'ils
avaient besoin de quelqu'un de mon
village pour collaborer avec eux et à
cause de moi
il demandait maintenant à ma femme de
collaborer aussi lui et sa femme devait
espionner des membres de leur communauté
je savais que si j'espionné ces gens je
les mettrai en danger ils se seraient
arrêtés ou torturés ou même tuer ma
femme et moi on avait un choix difficile
à faire soit de rester et de collaborer
ou bien de s'enfuir
on a décidé de s'enfuir c'était une
décision déchirante mais ça aurait été
plus difficile de rester parce qu'on
aurait eu l'impression d'avoir du sang
sur les mains
en collaborant avec ce gouvernement saïd
et sa famille partent de l'arabie
saoudite
il n'aurait jamais pensé un jour quitter
son pays n'ont pas même une seconde je
n'étais pas d'accord avec tout dans mon
pays mais c'est mon pays
tu veux rester avec tes amis avec tes
proches dans ta communauté
quand je voyais des gens s'enfuir je ne
pouvais pas imaginer ce qu'il ressentait
mais maintenant je suis à leur place au
retour le canada est de plus en plus
convoité par ceux qui fuient l'arabie
saoudite
[Musique]
je m'appelle à sa loi j'ai un des quatre
ans j'ai quitté l'arabie saoudite parce
que les lois ne protège pas les
fraudeurs en avril dernier
salwa al zahrani prend la fuite avec sa
jeune soeur en pleine nuit à l'insu de
ses parents ont vu laisser paraître que
les femmes mènent une bonne vie qu'elles
ont des droits
conduire ou pour travailler
dans les faits ce n'est pas le cas sauf
pour quelques exceptions cassino philo
mais pour s'échapper elle doit voler son
propre passeport qui se trouve chez son
frère puis réserver des billets d'avion
en cachette une erreur aurait pu me
coûter la vie fuir sa famille sans que
personne ne s'en doute c'est aussi ce
qu'a réussi à faire
raf mohamed le mois dernier je ne sors
pas tant que je n'ai pas vu le haut
commissariat pour les réfugiés
je demande l'asile sont retranchés dans
un hôtel en thaïlande
la jeune femme de 18 ans fait circuler
son appel à l'aide sur twitter en
quelques jours à peine son histoire fait
le tour du monde et les nations unies
nous ont demandé d'offrir le satut
d'asile à à mademoiselle and call que
nous ce que nous avions à faire
elle trouve refuge au canada en entrevue
à bbc
elle raconte avoir été victime de
violences aux mains de sa famille
l'attend passagers du risqué ma vie pour
avoir ma liberté ma soeur ma plus grande
crainte était de me faire prendre
j'aurais disparu fff
si quelqu'un me renvoie la balle je vais
écopé de six mois de prison et 80 coups
de fouet et ira chez les saoudiens sont
de plus en plus nombreux à fuir leur
pays
ceux qui ont demandé l'asile au canada
aussi leur nombre est en hausse presque
constante depuis près de 10 ans
atteignant 362 en 2017 en septembre 2018
plus de 400 demandes étaient toujours
devant la commission de l'immigration et
du statut de réfugié
selon les données de l'onu le canada
arrive au deuxième rang des pays
d'accueil des réfugiés de l'arabie
saoudite
derrière les etats unis c'est à cause de
la réputation du canada sait qu'il a une
approche humanitaire
saïd et maintenant réfugiés au québec la
hausse récente des demandes provenant de
son pays ne l'étonnent planté cette
augmentation est logique
parce que depuis l'arrivée de mbs c'est
plus difficile qu'avant de vivre dans ce
pays sa loi est aussi présentement au
canada
elle espère y obtenir le statut de
réfugié raf
elle a déjà ce statut elle entend
continuer à se battre pour les femmes
mais à partir du canada
je n'aurais pu rien faire en arabie
saoudite
d'autres avant moi ont réclamé des
changements elles sont aujourd'hui en
prison
exposées à la torture je ne voulais pas
ça un endroit où on peut pas nier qu'on
a un problème
la communauté observe les ong publie des
rapports
il refuse de reconnaître publiquement
qu'il y ait un problème depuis que le
canada a demandé à l'arabie saoudite de
libérer de prison des militants des
droits de la personne des tensions
diplomatiques demeure certes nos deux
pays discutent mais nous n'avons
toujours pas d'ambassadeurs en poste
quant aux étudiants saoudiens certains
ont été autorisés à terminer leurs
études au canada nous demande de
commentaires auprès des affaires
étrangères saoudiennes sont restés sans
réponse le meurtre d'un journaliste
cachot guise a été absolument
inacceptable et on exige encore des mers
réponse de la ravissante et le canada
fait partie des pays qui réclament une
enquête approfondie et transparente sur
le meurtre de jamal khashoggi lidl qui
tous si contrôlant que monsieur a sabré
le prince salman et perdu contrôle de sa
garde rapprochée comme ça ça me paraît
très très invraisemblable
ottawa examine aussi les permis
d'exportation de véhicules blindés
canadien à l'arabie saoudite un contrat
d'une valeur de 15 milliards de dollars
ce qui est arrivé avec le canada puis à
jamal a tout révélé mbs voulait se
présenter comme le réformateur du
système en arabie saoudite
mais maintenant tout le monde sait que
la réalité est tout autre
mohammed bin salman n'est pas un
réformateur
ce sont des jours noirs qui l'attendent
je ne crois pas qu'il va devenir le roi
tous n'en sont pas convaincus il n'ira
nulle part
les saoudiennes ne laisserons personne
leur dire comment gérer leur pays
peu importe le sort que l'avenir réserve
à mbs
les critiques vont continuer à se faire
entendre
i'm not scared je n'ai pas peur
je serai plus prudent mais je vais
continuer ce que je fais je ne serais
pas surpris que certains dissidents
deviennent plus discret et votre croix
mais pour d'autres ce sera peut-être le
contraire
comme si en essayant de faire taire un
homme ils en auront finalement réveillé
des douzaines
je crois que le régime saoudien devrait
nous craindre davantage maintenant car
notre revenu bien sûr que le régime
devrait avoir plus peur qu'une on y
forme maintenant on se trouve
un mot en terminant sur les suite à cet
assassinat horrible du journaliste jamal
khashoggi le nu anomie une rapporteur
spécial agnès callamard qui a déclaré ce
jeudi que ce meurtre a été planifié et
perpétré par l'arabie saoudite et elle
doit produire son rapport au conseil des
droits de l'homme en juin prochain
[Musique]